if you're a fan of brony james you
should stop scrolling and here's why
there's a lot of speculation on what
brawny is going to do after high school
what we know for sure is that lebron
wants to play with bonnie in the league
barney's coming off of peach jam
averaging 16 points six rebounds and
five assists in six games and is headed
into his senior year at sierra canyon
he is currently ranked 43rd in the
country and his recruitment process has
been under wraps from the public
most recruiting sites say he has
interest from schools like duke kansas
unc and more espn even shows that he
holds off from kentucky however
according to a recent report by adam
finkelstein the schools currently
involved with ronnie are duke usc ucla
michigan ohio state and memphis but will
ronnie even touch a college campus he
could always take a prep year take the
g-league out or even hoop overseas
granny is eligible for the 2024 nba
draft if he chooses the one and done
round he showed a lot of improvements in
his game at peace jam and scouts were
taking notice he's always been able to
shoot the ball but what we liked was
that he was more aggressive getting
downhill attacking the basket and
playing off to pick him real well barney
just wrapped up his final year of aau
and he's heading into his senior year at
sierra canyon this fall so what do y'all
think what should ronnie do after high
school
and that's why i think